it's not easy living in close quarters
with lots of hungry people in the middle
of winter for the yellow jackets that's
just the tip of the iceberg and most of
season two's second episode did a
serviceable job of showing how these
things were starting to draw them apart
taking a dump in the Pea bucket is not
something they're gonna let slide and by
the end of the episode they're in
desperate need of something to bring
them back together there was another
back and forth between Shauna and still
dead Jackie that ended with the former
telling the ladder to stop and Jackie
reminding her that she was the one
holding the knife the whole dynamic
exists inside her head and there's a lot
of that going down throughout the
episode
hungry at Mary's making dinner
stop moving it's not what you're hungry
for in the case of Thai things are
happening that she doesn't quite
understand adult Lottie seems to be less
than honest about things she's seen and
Travis is experiencing what is at least
spiritual if not Supernatural coming
into this season I think that was what I
was most excited to see how the
different characters would react to
these things that will inevitably happen
and what they do to try to make sense of
the horrors we imagine are coming their
way based on that it's kind of
refreshing that we got to the active
cannibalism so soon we knew it was
coming and actually that a much worse
version is still on the horizon so let's
get to it and see how they grapple with
it after the fact also the way it was
shot and cut with this hedonistic Greek
or Roman looking Feast hints at a sort
of a group delusion of how they're
processing what amounts to a not that
surprising choice they make given the
circumstances surprising or not there is
a major social taboo that is built into
eating human flesh and it's one that
coach Ben isn't ready to Overlook at
this point in the story that shoots him
up to the top of the list of characters
we don't expect to survive this ordeal
possibly overtaking Steve as the one who
feels like they're in the most immediate
Danger on top of that there was so much
other stuff that happened in edible
complex almost too much to the point
that I had a little trouble deciding on
how to put this recap together I decided
to jump around in time and try to stick
to each of the characters though I'm
gonna have to do a little bit of jumping
around there too and I think it makes
sense to start with Misty since the
interesting stuff that's happening with
her is somewhat disconnected from what's
happening in the rest of the episode in
1996 we don't get a ton of Misty we see
that her friendship with Crystal is
blooming we sort of see them hanging
around in the background in the shots
around the cabin imari delivers the
comment that oh great there are two of
you now to show that other people are
picking up on this new bond that they're
developing other than that you might
take her question about it being girl or
boy poop as a clue that she's the one
who is the guilty party but overall most
of what we see is about how everyone in
the cabin is getting tired of living
together in the present day things are a
lot more exciting we get our first look
at her fellow citizen detective putting
the sick in forensics Misty made a post
on the show's equivalent of Reddit
asking for hacking help to find out if
the security camera she discovered
outside in Nat's room in the last
episode recorded anything Elijah Wood's
character who's named Walter according
to IMDb responds by saying he can help
her out but only if she stops [__]
on his Adam Martin theories this leads
to another great faux Reddit moment as
she fires off her reply and then
instantly realizes she makes a mistake
so she has to struggle through the
anxiety over whether or not she should
edit it Walter then shows up at her work
and manages to sneak a note into the
refrigerator so she'll Discover it when
she goes to grab her lunch
bubble baths
walks in the rain
muscular calves
because we know who he is and Misty
doesn't this all comes off as a cute cat
and mouse sort of thing but I'm super
curious as to how he found out where she
worked and where she puts her lunch box
and what all that means about who he is
and how Misty got on his radar I mean I
suppose it's possible that the downvote
triggered him to the point of borderline
stalking her but Misty is also famous
from the plane crash so there could be
more going on
the note is written in invisible ink so
she doesn't figure that part out until
later after decoding it it tells her he
thinks the camera's a dummy and sets up
what I imagine is an incredibly exciting
Meetup for Misty to go interview a man
that's been staying at the hotel for
three months that man might be Randy
since we saw that he was basically
living there in season one and that's
interesting because he's one of the few
people alive that knows about Jeff's
involvement in the blackmail he also
knows Misty though so I'm not sure how
any of that would actually play out but
as I said this is all extremely up
Misty's alley the common interest in
being citizen detectives is internet
prowess and potential hacking skills and
a date that involves impersonating law
enforcement to collect information for a
case so it's a great setup that the
whole thing starts with her being in
opposition to him because he's looking
into Adam which is based on her wanting
to protect Shauna all of this should go
a long way toward keeping Misty's
present day timeline interesting though
speaking of Adam and Shauna the local
law enforcement officer and childhood
friend of Natalie Kevin tan stops by her
home looking for information about Adam
they have texts or at least records that
they were texting each other so he has
some questions Shauna decides to lie
which doesn't seem like a great idea and
has to be saved by Cali who interrupts
their conversation she's still working
through her feelings related to finding
the remains of Adam's ID in the barbecue
and heads to a local bar to do some day
drinking where she engages in some
flirting with a new character who turns
out to be Kevin's partner he sets her up
by floating a fake story about his
parents and gets the information he was
looking for when she confirms that her
mother was having an affair things
aren't looking great for the sedakis and
Jeff doesn't appear in this episode at
all things are also not looking great
for taisa in either timeline in the past
the man with no eyes makes an appearance
and almost leads her off a cliff while
she sleepwalking fan wakes up and
notices she's gone in time to track her
down and wake her up before it's too
late I wouldn't say this is an answer to
what's going on with Ty but it does feel
like a revelation you can't even say for
sure that it was leading her to her
death let alone say if it's connected to
any of the other unexplained stuff we've
been seeing and it does stand out that
we see the symbol on the tree after she
gets up what's more important though is
how Ty reacts and in some ways
overcompensates for not being able to
understand what's happening van suggests
that she go to Lottie and she rejects
that out of hand and she even goes as
far as telling band that she doesn't
want her to talk to her either in the
present she tries so hard to stay awake
through coffee and just general sleep
deprivation that she either hallucinates
that Sammy came to the house or she
falls asleep and the bad one takes over
either way she calls Simone who comes
over to find out Sammy isn't there they
notice that his bedroom window is open
so they go searching but get get a call
from the school to say he's been waiting
there the whole time Simone tells her
she needs help and then Ty scowls at her
before running the light and driving
into an accident in the intersection the
other car hits Simone's side but it's
not exactly clear if this is something
tied to on purpose or which Ty was
driving at that moment the sound design
catches your attention because this tie
is making the crazy face Simone
continues saying I won't let you be his
mother like this but you can barely hear
it it also Cuts back to show the scenes
with Sammy again to show that she was
alone the whole time and there was
another scene earlier where she was
looking in the mirror and the reflection
is sort of doing its own thing again it
looks like the bad one is acting
independently of her exactly what's
happening is never clear and maybe it
never will be but it all reinforces the
idea that it's not something she can
choose to ignore and that Simone is
probably right that not seeking help is
a mistake
another character who made what feels
like a big mistake this week is team Nat
although part of her motivations are
rooted in Good Intentions the other part
is rooted in her dislike of lottie's
emerging role and shaping the group's
decisions and the way that Travis has
this newfound interest in that I think
there will be more revealed and that
Natalie's feelings go beyond simple
teenage jealousy but we see that that
does exist when she's watching them
through the window when they go on their
hunt Nat brings it up and when Travis
doesn't take her side they make a
decision to split up this gives her the
chance to put her plan into action she
cuts her leg and puts the blood on a
pair of hobbies pants that she brought
with her and then shows them to Travis
telling him that she found them hanging
from a branch since Javi should be dead
you can understand where she's coming
from she wants to give him closure so
that he can move on but based on
everything else that's happening you
have to imagine that this will end up
causing her problems it does create this
situation where she can be the there for
him and it brings them together to share
this moment they even have sex that
night back at the cabin but given that
Lottie tells him she still feels Hobbies
alive and that Travis has visions of her
while they're making love it all feels
like it's leading to further
complications the visions of Lottie in
the room with them are strange because
it's happening at this intimate moment
it comes off as a desire for her
sexually at first but when you look at
it closer he's not engaging with her in
that way what works about this for me is
that Natalie's trying to give Travis
something she thinks he needs but he's
responding more to the faith that Lottie
is offering him and wanting to believe
that hobby is still alive you see that a
little bit in their conversation when
they're hiking and her response is to
try to fix things in the way that makes
the most sense to her as mentioned I do
think there's some Garden variety
jealousy at play but I also think Nat is
jealous because she fears that Lottie
can give Travis something she can't in
that sense it's not romantic or sexual
it's about getting through this
incredibly difficult time and trying to
live a life rather than just surviving
it's about trying to make sense of
things you can't explain and if not
believes the way to do that is through
their bond through the connection that
they have you can understand why she
would be opposed to him seeking
spiritual Solutions through Lottie in
the end those Visions hint that he'll
likely head in that direction so her
fabricating the evidence of hobbies
demise feels like it will be the
Catalyst for a split between them Beyond
her interactions with Travis and Nat in
the real world and his Visions there's
not a lot going on with Lottie in the
past in this episode I did think it
stood out that a lot of members seem to
look to her as a leader though at
different points when things come up it
seemed like the group waited for her
opinion before they made any decisions
in the present we get a better idea of
what kind of person she's become there's
a short scene on the grounds of her
compound where she's talking to Nat that
that presents a contrast between what
she says and what you see Natick uses
her of leading occult which it sure
looks like that's what she's doing but
she disagrees saying that she runs an
intentional Community turning suffering
into strength so they can live as their
best selves the whole conversation
continues this way it's heliotrope not
purple she sent people to watch Nat not
kidnap her and so on all the while she's
wearing a gold Rolex and tosses out a
drink that her follower messed up after
one sip it all establishes she's gifted
in her ability to spin things and
unsurprisingly Nat isn't buying into it
as promised she does tell her what she
knows about Travis saying he called her
the night he died convinced the
Wilderness was calling him and the only
way to make it stop was to get as close
as possible to death he believes that
when van and Lottie almost died they saw
something and he wants that too this
part at least seems plausible and I
think this and their early earlier
conversation together set the stage for
a story that we should expect is not
entirely true for example after she
calms him down by putting her hand on
his chest she says she thought she got
through to him and that she only wished
she hadn't fallen asleep at this point
Nat asked why she didn't call her and
she responds that she brought it up but
that Travis said not to because she
would only make things worse the way she
delivers this seems suspect because it
seems insensitive toward Nat who she's
supposedly trying to help it feels like
a small lie or at least a twisting and
it makes you wonder how much of what she
says you should believe what she says is
that she woke up and found him missing
he left his bank account information and
the note that said tell him that she was
right she then went to where he worked
and he had arranged candles in the shape
of the symbol and was going to lift
himself by the neck using a crane until
he passed out he tells her that he needs
her help to get back down but if she
refuses he'll just do it himself again
this might all be plausible it's a
terrible plan but nothing about Travis's
situation says he's making good
decisions she does agree to help and
says that as soon as he goes unconscious
she'll lower him back down what she
tells that is that the button stuck when
she tried to do that what we see is that
happens and she panics although it jumps
out right away that he's close to the
ground compared to where he was when
Natalie and Misty discovered him in
season one while this is going on we
hear Laura Lee saying put your faith in
him your Guiding Light and she has a
vision where you see her during her
baptism in the lake intercut with images
of Laura Lee that day and then a
staggering version of her walking
towards Lottie at first this is a
soothing experience but then Laura Lee
sort of decomposes in real time and
Lottie starts to scream there's a quick
flash of a bloody character's face on
the screen and then when she looks back
at Travis he's now up in the air as high
as when Nat found him at the very least
Lottie is withholding everything about
the vision she had from that but she
could also be twisting the details about
Travis's death the fact that she didn't
contact her at all and just sent people
to watch her instead doesn't really make
sense considering they hadn't been
staying in touch I guess based on their
conversation she had been keeping track
of her at least how many times she's
been in rehab but I think we need to
know more about what happened in the
past before any of lottie's present day
motivations will become clear Nat
doesn't believe she's telling her
everything and says that she's gonna put
a stop to what's happening but learns
that she can't leave Lottie who I guess
technically goes by Charlotte now even
though I'm not going to start calling
her that unless there's a good reason to
tells her she'll have to stay the night
and that at least she'll be safe then
she goes back to her room where she's
not impressed with the heliotrope
clothes they leave for her and when she
falls asleep briefly we see some flashes
of what looks like an EMT bringing her
back from what is most likely an OD
there are two men there with an oxygen
mask in the foreground and when they
move you can can see what looks like
Travis behind them I don't know what
else to say about this except it brings
to mind what Travis said about a
near-death experience and since it's
from her point of view it seems like
Natalie probably had one that's pretty
much everything that's going on in the
present day so let's go back to the past
for the main course I mentioned that
Shawna was continuing to talk with
Jackie's corpse and she convinced her to
braid her hair to cover up the fact that
she was missing an ear this leads to
doing her makeup and that leads to Ty
freaking out when she sees her it's kind
of funny how bad this looks but also
kind of sad since Jackie's ghost was
taunting her for being useless behind a
mirror and US knowing that this is
essentially Shauna talking to herself
there was a brief divide in how
frightening a thing this is for Shauna
to be doing Lottie was sympathetic and
Thai was not which makes sense Ty can't
control her sleepwalking or confront it
in a healthy way so you can see how she
might want to control or try to control
what other people are doing doing and
laughs out at something as freaky as
this they eventually decide to burn the
body because the ground is still frozen
and that's the reason they didn't bury
her in the first place there's a lot of
great acting throughout these sequences
and you do feel for Shauna even though
you know she'd cut a piece of Jackie's
arm off and probably ate that too they
built a pyre which makes you wonder how
van might feel about that and then
Aquila suggests saving the jacket which
all things considered seems like a good
idea Shauna protests this though because
if they took the jacket off then they
would see what she did to her arm and
then she goes full Mama Bear protecting
her Cubs mode to back everyone else off
Lottie does see the cut on the arm and
helps her cover it up and then removes
her heart necklace and gives it the
Shauna of course we know this will make
a future appearance around the pit
girl's neck so now we can see how it
circulates amongst the survivors Nat and
Travis return and a fight breaks out
because Lottie is still convinced that
javi's still alive despite the fact that
they're carrying those those bloody
shredded pants so Shawna grabs the torch
and gets ready to burn her best friend's
body she says some words and it really
hit me when she says that she'll never
have another friend like her because it
underlines the fact that you do only
have those kinds of relationships when
you're at that age she is losing a piece
of herself here and even though the
group has lost so much by this point it
is another layer of their innocence
slipping away they all walk inside but
we only get to see what Travis and Knack
get up to while they're together and
he's having visions of Lottie the camera
moves through the forest in a way that
suggests that there's an unseen Force at
play there's basically a perfectly
placed gust of wind that dislodges snow
from the branches that covered Jackie's
Burning Body I suppose this turns The
Cremation into a smoking and the smell
of a roasted body wakes everyone up to
their credit they contemplate what
they're about to do even for a while
after Shauna says she wants us to we see
that she makes the first move and
through the intercut banquet scene we
see that they start off tentatively
before letting loosen gimming into the
gorging you get the impression that
everyone partakes except for Coach Ben
who looks horrified and walks away and
closes the door behind him that puts him
in the out group of what I think is just
him I think he's the only member at the
banquet table I think we only see the
name characters from season one but I do
think you see the character named Jen
that they introduced in last week's
episode come out of the cabin when the
others do and I can't think of a good
reason why they wouldn't be included in
the cannibalism so I'll assume they were
unless we find out something different I
guess this works I saw some people
saying that this was a great way to show
what was happening without the gore and
that kind of just made me think that
maybe you're watching the wrong show
maybe don't pick the one that opens with
the cast hunting down one of their
teammates and eating them my first
thought when I saw these images in the
teasers and sort of the way I imagined
it going in was that it would somehow be
sanitary from their perspective not like
we can't see this because it's too
graphic but you know they can't really
process the truth of what's Happening
like they're replacing a brutal truth
with something more palatable and they
do actually get fairly Savage while
looking downright gluttonous but
gluttony in regards to fruit and wine is
something altogether different than
Jackie meat I don't think it was a bad
choice necessarily I just think it's
silly if the cannibalism show doesn't
think its fan base is okay with seeing
cannibalism that's why I think if it
works it works because of the way we
choose to make sense of things and just
sort of how we remember how memories
work and what we decide to hold on to
this seems to line up with Nat saying
that Travis never believed in any of
this stuff in season one because after
this episode it's clear he believed in
some of it and maybe a lot of it if you
believe adult Lottie which makes me
think that when she said that what she
was really saying is what she chooses to
believe and remember about how he felt
it's a thing that everyone does to some
extent even if you've never been in a
survival situation I think there are a
lot of interesting places they can go
from there and I would be excited to see
them lean into this idea of memory and a
general inability to deal with reality
or just exploring the way the different
characters react to whatever they're
experiencing and all of that kind of
stuff plus there's a lot of other stuff
that might not be clear yet like it's
possible that Tai was the bad one
whenever this happened and she'll wake
up and be horrified by what happened so
I don't want to come off like I'm not
optimistic about where this might go
because overall as I said I'm glad they
got there so that we can see what this
does to them as a group and I think most
of what didn't work leading up to the
big moment might work better when we see
how things come together because I was
thinking we were watching the group
Splinter apart I wasn't expecting this
situation to arise that would bring them
back together the thing I didn't like
was the shot where the camera swoops in
before before the snow falls onto the
body it made it feel like it would be
very hard to show something like that
and then pull back and say well actually
there's nothing Supernatural going on
here at all they didn't go as far as
confirming that's why the snow fell in
such a way that perfectly sets things up
so that they could cross that line it
could be an act of God or whatever but I
don't know why you would choose to
present it that way if that was the case
I suppose it might have come off as
funny if you just saw the snow drop from
above but this looked like something
made it happen and I'm not opposed to
the idea of going down the supernatural
route especially if they have a good
explanation for that I've just been
enjoying that tension that is there
whenever you don't know if it's one way
or the other and now it feels like it's
a little bit of a different show what
locks that down is it wasn't from any of
the characters point of view it was
something that just existed for us to
see as the viewer otherwise I enjoyed it
it was nice to see the man with no eyes
there's a lot of interesting stuff going
on between tnat and Travis and how
Lottie fits into that that makes the
adult Lottie and that stuff a lot more
interesting the Misty Reddit stuff was
maybe too relatable when she left out
the word wild before Goose chases I
thought to myself I get it the word
before it started with the W-2 so I
totally see how she skipped right over
that super excited to see where Elijah
Wood's character fits in and how that
changes what's going on in the adult
Misty timeline I wasn't familiar with
the word heliotrope so I looked that up
and noticed that there's an old
surveying instrument that has that same
name there might be some Clues there
which I'll try to look at before I make
my next video I thought it was
interesting that they mentioned that
Shawna was seven months pregnant and
that that means they have probably about
a year left in the wilderness before
they get rescued and I'm curious to find
out who took the dump in the P Bucket
please like this video If you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon